al momento de hablar de economía en
france24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida
a mi compañero luís méndez louis
empezamos hablando de chile porque dos
sindicatos ya están en huelga así que si
es que trabajadores de estatal chilena
codelco la mayor productora de cobre en
el mundo iniciaron cuerda este jueves
sumándose al paro en otra mina en el
norte del país esto sucede justo cuando
otros sindicatos con más de 2.000
afiliados de la mina escondida uno de
los más grandes yacimientos de cobre en
el mundo también continúan negociando
con la angloaustraliana bhp billiton dos
de los sindicatos de la división andina
que es una cantera ubicada en la región
de valparaíso expresaron en un
comunicado su rotundo rechazo y dicen
que ha sido motivado por la intención de
la empresa de quitar beneficios
históricos como la salud no hacerse
cargo de mejorar los beneficios sociales
y desconocer el escenario que presenta
el precio del cobre para entregar una
mejor oferta está huelga se suma a la
que iniciaron esta semana un grupo de
más de 300 trabajadores en el yacimiento
de caserones en el norte del país lo que
supondría que a partir de ésta semana
más de 1200 mineros han detenido sus
actividades pero este jueves entró en
vigencia la ley de repartidores en
españa' que se trata de la nueva norma
que había sido aprobada en mayo exige a
las empresas de reparto de alimentos que
contraten a sus conductores como
empleados y no como contratistas
independientes la ley cubre a unos 30
mil empleados de las aplicaciones
digitales de domicilios y también les
obliga a las empresas como globo y la
estadounidense uber a informarles a los
representantes legales de los
trabajadores cómo funcionan sus
algoritmos para asignar viajes y asignar
las calificaciones las compañías
advierten que la norma amenaza una
industria de más de 800 millones de
dólares en techo de libro con sede en
reino unido ha dicho que plantea salir
del mercado español a la espera de una
consulta obligatoria con sus
trabajadores y muchos de ellos también
se han opuesto argumentando que el
modelo de autónomos le da mayor
flexibilidad
louis la economía británica creció pero
no llega a niveles pre pandémicos como
es eso es que cifras oficiales muestran
que el producto interno bruto de ese
país creció un 48 por ciento en el
segundo trimestre de 2021 frente al
trimestre anterior después de que se
levantaran todas las medidas de bloqueo
también tuvo en junio su quinto mes
consecutivo de crecimiento sin embargo
se mantienen más de cuatro puntos
porcentuales por debajo del nivel pre
pandémicos pero escuchamos que fue lo
que dijo un economista
de las cifras de hoy muestran que la
economía se está recuperando con mucha
fuerza es el crecimiento trimestral más
rápido en el grupo de países del g7 y
evidencia que nuestro plan de empleo
está funcionando pero no soy
complaciente el impacto que han
experimentado nuestra economía y
nuestras finanzas públicas es importante
y nos llevará tiempo recuperarnos por
completo
pues pasamos a honduras que aumentó sus
remesas en una tercera parte es que el
banco central de esta nación ubica en
centroamérica reveló que en los primeros
meses de 2021 recibió 4 mil 74 millones
de dólares en remesas esto representa un
incremento de 36 2% más que el mismo
período 2020 cuando las remesas
estuvieron levemente por debajo de los 3
mil millones de dólares la razón de este
buen comportamiento es el mejor
desempeño de la economía de eeuu porque
es éste el principal origen de los
envíos hacia las familias hondureñas
provenientes del exterior es decir más
de nueve de cada diez dólares el resto
proviene de españa canadá y panamá
principalmente los indicadores por
street cerró el jueves con ligeros
avances en el dow jones de industriales
su principal indicador y el selectivo
standard and poor's se volvió a notar
nuevos máximos históricos por tercer día
consecutivo por su parte en américa
latina la bolsa argentina cerró
prácticamente sin cambios mientras que
la de sao paulo tuvo un fuerte descenso
en medio del vaivén político que se vive
en el país y vamos con la cifra del día
tiene que ver en este caso con los 2500
millones de dólares por este valor la
empresa alemana de artículos deportivos
adidas prendió arriba al grupo
estadounidense authentic brands hace 15
años había había pagado 3 mil 800
millones de dólares por esta firma luís
méndez con la información económica en
france 24 muchas gracias a ustedes
muchas gracias por acompañarnos quédense
con nosotros
[Música]